this week in Westminster the new brexit
secretary was slapped down by the Prime
Minister for saying Britain may leave
the EU single market the new
international trade secretary called
British business fat and lazy and this
morning the new foreign secretary
launches a campaign group calling for a
hard brexit in what appears to be an
effort to put pressure on the Prime
Minister Boris Johnson calls for the
return of control over borders laws
money and trade from the EU to the UK
well high-profile leave campaign around
conservative MEP Daniel Hannan is live
now in Basingstoke and a very good
morning to you well let's work through
some of those comments what about Liam
Fox this.c is he right about British
business and their main being
dereliction of duty to export more I
think Liam would accept that he phrased
that badly and which of us hasn't done
that at one time or another I know I
certainly have I suspect even you might
have done doumitt from time to time in
the course of a basically very good
speech talking about the export
opportunities that will now be open to
us as a global country engaged with
global markets he I think phrased one
section in a way that he might I'm sure
regrets now okay and you don't think you
should have phrase it like that what
about Sir David David send the brexit
secretary saying well Britain may have
to leave the single market not
government policy yet we're not sure
what it is but um do you agree with mr.
Davis I mean the thing is in this
century you know more than 90 percent of
the economic growth is going to come
from outside the EU and the challenge
for Britain is to be part of that growth
to be plugged in so that we benefit as
Africa Asia South America and the other
surging parts of the world push ahead
and in order to do that we can't rely on
the EU because we know that the EU is
very reluctant to sign trade deals with
these parts of the world it's been
talking for nine years with India hasn't
done anything refuses to talk to China
and so the huge opportunity for us is to
return to being a global maritime
merchant country of course trading with
our friends in Europe but no longer
being subject to the external tariffs of
the European Union the customs union and
the regulation of all of our domestic
Commerce and Industry of
we're gonna have to meet EU standards
when selling to the EU just like we have
to meet Russian standards when we sell
to Russia but no longer will we have to
apply burdensome and expensive
regulations either to our domestic
commerce and industry or to that
which we we sell beyond the EU and this
characterization of the debate is soft
and hard brexit do you think the the
nature of the results should inform that
debate slightly the the 52:48 in favor
of brexit if it had been 6040 with that
of signaled hard brexit this one this
result means something more nuanced I
mean I think it's a very fair point it
was a very marginal result I think that
that imposes on the winning side an
obligation to take very seriously the
top concerns of the losing side both in
terms of continued trade with the EU and
in terms of continued participation in
various research and educational
programs and so on I think we we need to
listen to what the 48% want and I think
we should have the closest relationship
with the EU compatible with being a
sovereign country think of it a bit like
Canada with the US and Canada also has a
federal state on its doorstep it isn't
part of that Federation it makes its own
laws but it has the closest relation in
terms of military alliance security
links trade and so on and that I think
should be our model we want to work very
closely with our friends and allies
we'll also our suppliers and customers
in Europe but making our own laws so as
Boris Johnson is the foreign secretary
pushing it too far no I think what you
just showed Boris there in the clip
saying we want control over our own laws
money democracy absolutely that's what
people voted for having taken back
control that doesn't mean that we sort
of you know sworn off and don't talk to
our friends and neighbors I think there
is a very good case having taken back
jurisdiction for in some cases
replicating through treaties as a as a
friend and neighbor bilaterally some of
the arrangements that we have with our
allies in Europe you know we're not
talking about just having a trade
relationship with them we're going to
have continued close intergovernmental
cooperation close military alliance and
so on but it'll be on the basis that
Parliament and therefore we ultimately
decide what happens one of the other
things Boris
Johnson is rue remembered from from the
campaign of course is standing beside
that bus with the 350 million pounds for
the NHS on it now it may come down to a
hundred million pounds a week but do you
think Theresa May should not have
reneged on that well it's hardly
reneging it wasn't a promise that she
made I mean the the s I think by the way
porous had been Prime Minister I think
he would have felt morally obliged to
honor that but the essence of a
referendum is that you're instructing a
government a referendum isn't a general
election you know because we're not used
to them a lot of people struggle with
this if people voted leave they weren't
electing Boris they were voting to
instruct the government to get out of
the EU on the best terms we can get
advantageous ly to ourselves but also
being fair to our friends and allies in
Europe that is going to free up a lot of
the money that we're currently paying to
Brussels about how we now spend that
money of course will be a question for
the British people in Parliament ask you
we've had discussions before haven't we
mr. Hannon about the nature of the trade
deals and you feel it's a free-trade
arrangement a quick one from the UK
would be one of the best ways to go I've
just been talking to to a very
experienced trade negotiator and Michael
Johnson who says well he doesn't really
believe there is any such thing as free
trade and the downside of that is is
that some of the activities in the
country that does that the UK suffer
very badly indeed were thinking about
agriculture here certain industries and
steel industry the car industry he was
right to say that no country in the
world has ever pursued pure free trade
because as he correctly said there are
always vested interests there are always
industries that want protection
however the countries that have got
closest to that ideal whether it's
Switzerland or Hong Kong or Singapore
almost without exception have been
countries that have then grown more
quickly and the standard of living for
everybody in that country has tended to
rise faster than the countries that
retain distortions protections and
closed markets so of course we're not
going to be able to have eight a kind of
pure perfect open trade model because
there are going to be distortions here
I've been in politics long enough to
know that that's how it happens but the
well so we get to it the better it will
be for everyone and where there are
industries that particularly are going
to be affected by the transition so
actually farming is a good example right
we're in the Common Agricultural Policy
now outside it will have much cheaper
food it'll be a huge boon for almost
every family in the country as groceries
come down but when every other country
in the world every single one except New
Zealand subsidizes its farmers it would
be very difficult to say we're gonna be
the only ones who don't so what we
should do in that situation is simply
give a higher direct grant to our
farmers than at present rather than
having tariffs quotas or other trade
barriers that's by far the cheaper and
more effective way of doing it and
lastly mr. Hanna may I ask you about I
think what we'd all agree would be a
very unwelcome dimension of the brexit
vote I mean do you feel there has been
an increase in hate crimes involving
foreign nationals in the UK hmm
I mean you phrased the question there as
though it was a given because you called
it an unwelcome consequence I don't
accept that and I think it's it's a
tendentious thing to put the question in
the way that you do there has been for a
long period a rise in the reporting of
hate crime incidents because of the way
in which the police have their websites
and treat every report as an incident
there hasn't been any increase in the
number of cases referred for prosecution
and some of the cases that the media
have jumped on have turned out to have
nothing to do with brexit at all so
there was a huge fuss about those
plankton in Newcastle who had a send
them all back repatriation banner those
idiots have been doing that every
weekend outside the Town Hall in
Newcastle for years it was nothing to do
with brexit similarly there was a case
that was supposedly about bricks it
inspired anti-polish graffiti it turned
out not to have been anything of the
kind
so I think there has been some slightly
irresponsible reporting of this of
course any kind of intolerance any kind
of hateful incident doesn't you know it
goes without saying that we all
condemned that but to insult 52% of the
British electorate by suggesting that
there is some connection between voting
to take back our laws and being
unpleasant to people who have made their
lives here I think that's a extremely
dangerous way of going